buongiorno buongiorno e grazie e niente
slide che è cuore e passione cuore e
passione perché adesso quando in questi
giorni parlavamo e pensavo ai 15 minuti
perché per noi il tempo è veramente
molto importante
è importante che quotidianamente
condividiamo
parliamo del tempo e organizzazione 10
secondi cambiano una partita una
settimana un mese una stagione però
quando ho visto i 15 minuti mi sono
venuti in mente i 15 anni di trento
dalla prima volta 15 anni 15 anni sono
l'allenatore più longevo su una panchina
di serie a come anni consecutivi come
anni complessivi ma non è che lo dico
per quello lo dico perché perché forse
riesce a sottolineare che tipo di lavoro
abbiamo fatto che tipo di condivisione
c'è stata abbiamo parlato organizzato
preso decisioni difficili cambiato in
corsa discusso diversi ma uguali ma
sempre parlando di lavoro sempre
mettendo il lavoro al centro mai le
persone e probabilmente questa cosa qui
ci ha permesso nel tempo e per così
tanto tempo di lavorare però lo metto un
attimo da parte perché c'è il prima e
venendo qua o pensando di venire qua per
la quarta volta perché a me le ricordo
tutte per la quarta volta mi è venuto in
mente la palestrina dell'inizio perché
ho un percorso un po differente non so
non è stato un grande giocatore
ho solo giocato e non sono stato
all'interno di un club importante
scolarizzato passatemi il termine
comunque all'interno di un club di serie
a dove alleni
i ragazzi dove sei assistente dove vivi
nei corridoi e senti parlare comunque
respiri l'aria direttamente no subito
dell'alto livello e invece non è stato
così
e vedendo come è venuta in mente la me
mi sono venuto in mente queste immagini
quattro volte oggi quando siamo andati
in serie a vincendo l'ultima partita la
promozione in serie a
mancavano dieci secondi alla fine
abbiamo fatto un canestro del più 10 io
ho iniziato a correre perché dicevo ai
miei giocatori di tornare in difesa per
fortuna si è alzato un mio giocatore mi
ha detto coach coach canestro da undici
non esiste è finita
ce l'abbiamo fatta tranquillo io sei
secondi cambia il mondo
quei sei secondi camminando mi hanno
fatto divenire lo stesso flash
la terza volta
entrando in uno spogliatoio nba prima di
una partita la nba
l'ingresso prima sul campo e poi dentro
lo spogliatoio con i giocatori nba
seduti intorno e un'altra volta
quando ho ascoltato l'inno da allenatore
di una nazionale al campionato europeo
queste in queste quattro volte ho avuto
l'immagine della palestrina di ponte san
giovanni alle porte di perugia
casteldebole alle porte di bologna che
mi piace nominarle non c'erano neanche
le tribune le banchette avevo i palloni
siccome il custode l'amico avevo anche
la chiave perché se qualcuno voleva
venire prima o lo chiamavo prima se
comunque qualcuno voleva rimanere dopo a
migliorare qualcosa io ero lì o lo
stimolavo rimanere o rimanevo con lui e
lo dico soprattutto perché sono due
città diverse perché ho preso e sono
andato ci vuole sempre una persona seria
con cui lavorare con cui condividere
questa cosa per fortuna l'ho trovata la
trovai però sono andato ma dove vai
vado ad allenare a che fare l'allenatore
ma di mestiere è professionalmente si
vediamo cosa succede
e me le ricordo perché intanto sono
immagini che mi sono rimaste in testa
sempre sempre perché alla base di tutto
la passione il sangue che che scorreva
nelle vene quando entravo in palestra e
parlavo con questi giocatori tra l'altro
per tanti anni sono stato il più giovane
delle categorie allenavo coetanei o
giocatori più vecchi e nelle serie
minori
avendo fatto una trafila diversa come
dice voi avendo anche capito che
bisognava vincere per andare su
bisognava fare qualcosa di diverso per
andare su perché non si ri non era
facile come quando ci cercavano
diplomati milite esenti automuniti a 21
anni
datemi the a team far tutto però ho
capito che quella cosa lì era una cosa
da fare in questo modo e sono riuscito
piano piano però quel campo lì è stata
la scuola e ci vuole invece anche dello
studio per cui parallelamente perché il
gioco evolve perché il gioco cambia
perché comunque non sei stato con tante
persone che te l'hanno insegnato male
sei andata e tu a cercare le sono andate
a cercare sono andato nelle palestre
negli uffici negli impianti di chi già
lo faceva di chi già era ad alto livello
il giorno prima della partita il giorno
dopo della partita a metà settimana dopo
un periodo positivo dopo un periodo
negativo dopo grandi litigate con tanto
amore per capire cosa e come venivano
gestite le persone perché la parte
emozionale ed emotiva è fondamentale è
fondamentale in ogni momento devi andare
a prendere le corde dell'anima delle
persone che lavorano con te che hanno
tutte comunque un ruolo sono tutte
importanti
vogliono tutte
se le importanti sia come squadra che
come staff perché anche lo staff tecnico
è fatto di professionisti unici nel loro
mestiere
otto persone 8 mansioni diverse 8
incarichi da mettere tutti insieme sullo
stesso binario senza però far perdere la
loro personalità non è non è facile e
credo che anzi lo so che il campo
comunque il lavoro sul campo mi ha dato
una grande mano perché impari anche
molto a condividere impari ad ascoltare
facendo alle volte finta di no ma impari
ad ascoltare chiedi ti fai buttare
addosso l'energia dagli altri perché tu
ne ha devi avere tanta e per tutti
quanti e hai bisogno di creare delle
condizioni per cui riceverla lì dipende
anche dallo spessore dei giocatori o dei
collaboratori questa cosa qui è stata
fondamentale e secondo me la passione
che abbiamo avuto mi dispiace ripetere
questo termine ma è veramente così è
stata la base anche del rischio
forse no ma non mi ha fatto neanche mai
pensare all'incoscienza di prendere
andare ma dove vai con con quali
sicurezze se non qualche persona che
voleva e vedeva che si potesse costruire
qualcosa
quella passione li secondo me ho avuto
la fortuna di condividerla con chi aveva
in mente dove arrivare ma aveva una
grande qualità che secondo me cioè io me
la sono sempre tenuta riuscire ad avere
degli obiettivi raggiungibili
nessuno dimentica la dove arrivare ma il
primo passo perché sennò si rischia di
pensare alla alla giu e poi ad aspettare
che non viene da solo piccoli obiettivi
durante la strada raggiungibili
adesso che che vedo sette minuti mi
vengono in mente anche i sette anni per
questa questo percorso
sette anni fa era lì eravamo lì c'era
mezzo metro e si casca va giù e si cade
va giù
dopo un percorso positivo dopo che
l'azienda perché lo sport ha sempre
guardato a come organizzare
aziendalmente le cose sempre
ora c'è un po di ritorno c'è un po di
scambio perché lo sport negli su
equilibri rappresenta molto la vita
vissuta
noi ci abbiamo sempre guardato a
quell'aspetto aziendale e nel momento in
cui abbiamo fatto il primo step
abbiamo cercato di farne altri volevamo
essere responsabili di 5mila persone
intorno a noi volevamo andare in campo
dicendo è pieno volevo andare in campo
dicendo mamma mia devo stare attento a
un patrimonio sotto le mani da
valorizzare anche perché la nostra
scelta in un territorio di lavoro in un
club di trentini che forse nel dna hanno
quel tipo di organizzazione di capacità
lavorativa era era molto importante e
quando siamo arrivati lì la passione
sapendo sempre da dove siamo arrivati
dove si aveva eravamo insomma prima da
dove siamo arrivati e che è stata alla
base di tutto ci ha permesso a un mezzo
passo dal cadere di spiccare
praticamente l'ultimo salto l'ultimo
volo perché poi è stato campionato vinto
coppa italia vinta campionato vinto
coppa italia vita serie a serie a europa
europa palestre e impianti da 20mila
persone parametri tecnici economici di
team completamente cambiati in
pochissimo tempo un frullatore noi gli
stessi noi evolvere la nostra
professionalità la capacità di stare
insieme per rimbalzarci delle delle idee
sempre con le dovute gerarchie con le
due senza invadere il territorio degli
altri ma mettendo il lavoro davanti ti
vengono in mente sempre i percorsi
precedenti perché anche quegli altri
spogliatoi avevano comunque gente che
magari nelle serie minori o lavorava o
studiava o comunque erano ex giocatori
erano mentalità leggermente
grazie però il denominatore comune era
come faccio a tenerli sullo stesso
binario
come faccio come faccio adesso la
squadra ora attualmente vive di molto di
multiculturalità tosta time out
antonio 5 una partita faccio un time out
of time out importante e 55 secondi per
dire due cose intelligenti nel facile
anche perché bisogna andare veramente a
colpire ma noi abbiamo americano
messicano olandese lettone portoghese
argentino italiani di varie zone
d'italia cioè non è problema della
lingua è un problema di come si vive di
come si offendono di come gioiscono di
come parlano di come tu devi e tu devi
dare a tutti un ruolo
tu devi dare a tutti un sentirsi
importante
tu devi dare a tutti la l'unicità che
rappresentano all'interno del gruppo ma
un team spalla spalla dove finisco io
cominci tu che è un lavoro
difficilissimo e non è vero che è
differente quando si comincia dalla
serie minore dalla palestrina dove i
palloni ce l'avevi sulla spalla non è
vero cambia la professionalità cambiano
l'esperienza ma come la gioia di un
risultato ottenuto è sempre lo stesso
nell'ultima categoria e nella prima è la
stessa perché è rapportata è gioia è
sentire che il lavoro ha portato frutti
altrettanto lo è nel momento in cui
lavoriamo con le persone ovviamente
l'aspetto multiculturale cambia nel
momento in cui devi ragionare iniziare a
pensare a capire come solo non si può
aspettare
tu aspetti meglio aspetto te ne abbiamo
nessuna parte dobbiamo trovarci in un
punto dobbiamo trovarci in un punto
il punto è il bene di tutti quanti
questa cosa qua non può esserci se è
solo
razionale non può esserci se solo
schematica e organizza organizzativa
serve una trasmissione dalle vene perché
poi si riporta negli occhi perché poi si
riporta anche nelle intuizioni si
riporta nel nel sapere quando è il
momento di fare una cosa e si riporta
anche nella non paura di rischiare uno
non può non cominciare perché è dura non
può non cominciare perché sarà dura non
può non cominciare perché però se poi
non va ma non se ne parla neanche
non se ne parlava che comincia lavora
però lo deve rendersi conto se è
veramente una cosa che riuscirà a non
abbandonare
io ci vado a letto perché quando insomma
veramente prima di spegnere la luce uno
dicevo non la mollo non la mollo
difficoltà o no non la mollo perché
quando entrò e superò la riga del campo
entro in palestra iniziano a muoversi
intorno a me sento dei brividi addosso
che penso e spero di trasmettergli e di
poterli ancora trasmettere grazie
[Applauso]